meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir haben uns noch sehr intensiven
verhandlungen zwischen cdu und csu
geeinigt so wie es dargestellt wurde
affentheater schmierentheater chaos was
auch immer die begriffe halte ich für
falsch weil das wenn es hart auf hart
kommt wird halt so verhandelt ich glaube
aber schon dass ein grund warum man sich
nicht einigen konnte und sich erst jetzt
eigentlich auch dass das einfach das
persönliche verhältnis zwischen frau
merkel und seehofer ist die können nicht
miteinander und und sie können jetzt
nach diesem streik noch weniger
miteinander glaube ich dass wir heute
nach hartem ringen und schwierigen tagen
einen wirklich guten kompromiss gefunden
dieser streit um zurückweisung scheint
jetzt erstmal gelöst zu sein aber das
ganze klima in der koalition zwischen
den parteien ist erst mal auf einem
vielleicht nicht im gefrierpunkt aber
dem doch sehr nahe alles was jetzt kommt
wird im schatten dieses streits
irgendwie stehen
selbst die selbst die frage wann
entscheidet frau merkel
ob sie aufhören will oder nicht wird
auch im lichte dieses streits gesehen
werden von ihr selber und auch von der
öffentlichkeit
die spd hat sich bislang sehr
zurückgehalten international
auseinandersetzung und das überraschende
heute morgen ist würde ich sagen dass
die spd jetzt nicht unbedingt sofort
sagt nein das tragen wir nicht mit
sondern sie stößt sich nur an einigen
begriffen und weist eben auf den punkt
hin dass es ohne absprache mit
österreich wohl nicht gehen werde
das wort was wohl geändert werden soll
ist der begriff transitzentrum das hatte
die spd vor mehreren jahren abgelehnt
also schon mal im gespräch war
allerdings für eine wesentlich größere
gruppe von also wir waren eigentlich für
alle
ich verstehe nicht so ganz warum jetzt
unbedingt das wort geändert werden muss
weil die sache bleibt dieselbe
aber das ist vielleicht für die spd in
auswahl ausweg um
um sich dann doch noch dazu
durchzuringen dem zuzustimmen
ich glaube kurzfristig wird die csu für
die landtagswahl im herbst nicht nicht
viel gewonnen haben weil es einfach
nicht goutiert wird wenn sich parteien
so zerstreiten also ich glaube die die
wähler wollen doch einfach ordnung
entscheidungsfreude und und
schnelligkeit oder oder regungslosigkeit
sagen wir mal so deswegen wird das der
kurzfristig der csu schaden langfristig
bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher ob es der
csu nicht nützt denn sie hat sich
durchgesetzt die politik findet in
umfragen zustimmung also große
zustimmung
und wenn jetzt nicht im monatsrhythmus
wieder solche streitereien kommen könnte
könnte das durchaus sein dass im oktober
viele leute sagen was
unterm strich hat die csu dann doch
unsere interessen ganz gut verorten und
umgekehrt muss man sagen dass die af.de
dass der afg die die munition so ein
bisschen ausgeht und die vorschläge die
sie jetzt noch machen kann
die da wird auch da werden auch viele
merken dass sie einfach nicht
realistisch sind
das spricht eigentlich dafür dass die
csu vielleicht stärker werden können das
was jetzt scheint diese klare
übereinkunft die in allen drei punkten
die sie gleich hören werden meiner
vorstellung entspricht erlaubt mir dass
ich das amt des bundesministeriums des
innern
für bau und heimat weiterführe